you've got to admit though if we're a
society that gets really upset about
jokes that's a sign we get a we got a
pretty goddamn good you know some guy in
Ukraine's getting his face shut off we
got people out here like zingers
always blows my mind when somebody gets
really upset about comedy I told a joke
one time this guy got pissed he goes you
got to apologize for that joke I was
like sorry he goes you didn't mean that
apology I'm like I know I didn't mean
the joke either you queef
what are we doing here
but you know maybe it's me I'm too
literal literal guy you know definitely
hurt me in some social interactions yeah
I remember just last week I was at a
party girl comes up and he goes are you
gay I was like no I'm not gay she goes
whoa
brother on being gay I'm like yeah I
know just saying I'm not she's like well
you're getting pretty defensive I'm like
well I'm not gay he's like well there's
nothing wrong with it I'm like I know
but I'm not
she wouldn't let it go eventually I got
annoyed I go what are you pregnant she
was like screw you I'm not pregnant I
was like whoa not the wrong being
pregnant